[Musik]
meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen episode
minecraft mit luca das bin ich und das
hier ist meine underground base die wir
der letzten episode gebaut haben danke
danke danke für euer zahlreiches
feedback hierzu hab das ding mega ab
gefeiert obwohl zeit nur mir erst mal so
eine kleine start-ups hier ist schon
einmal ganz kurz die lupe zu danke auch
nicht nur für das feedback sondern auch
für eure tipps und zwar wurden unter
anderem das sie geschrieben und zwar
luca baumann seine öfen ab das macht gar
keinen sinn bau dir da lieber
schmelzöfen hin das hat jetzt ergeben
dass ich dir jetzt abgebaut hat und
wieder hingesetzt haben und ich werde
mir dementsprechend jetzt einfach mal
zwei schmelzöfen bauen dafür werde ich
denen wir abbauen müssen und den hierauf
denn die benötige ich und ich benötige
auch noch glatte steine und zwar habe
ich davon nur ein
perfekt von daher raten wir hier vorne
einfach mal noch ein bisschen steine so
dass wir die glatte steine bekommen in
der zwischenzeit werde ich mich
allerdings auf die suche nach ein
bisschen nahrung bewegen ich habe hier
vorne machen
[Musik]
ich hasse diese teilen da wir auch in
die kommentare geschrieben wildbeeren
sind richtig gut ich kann nicht an
pflanzen und so das mag ich ja eh schon
die ganze zeit perfekte das habe ich
nichts zum essen
[Musik]
ich liebe diese bot aber irgendwie hast
auch darf mit den wild wären ja ein
bisschen dauert bis sie gewachsen sind
würde ich sagen würde ich mir jetzt hier
einfach mal ein bisschen seetang wie sie
robben lässt so ein bisschen
gesellschaft bei und dann kann ich den
seetang jetzt auch direkt in so einem
ofen reinpacken so dass sich
getrockneten seetang bekommen und mich
von dem zumindest erstmal zu beginn
dieses projekt ein bisschen ernähren
kann das ist allerdings nicht das
hauptziel für die heutige episode denn
das ist dieses ziel hier
und auch dieses ziel hier vorne
es wird auf jeden fall abgeben meine
lieben freunde denn wir machen heute
unsere erste höhlen expedition ich nehme
nun allerdings erst mal meine beiden
öfen und die eisen waren um einen
glatten stein und machen wir daraus zwei
schmelzhütten der sinn von schmelzöfen
ist dass sich darin angeblich ärzte
deutlich schneller
braten kann als es beispielsweise in
einem normalen ofen der fall wäre ich
habe auch hier noch 15 eisen waren übrig
und damit könnte ich mir auch mal ganz
kurz neben ein paar neue werkzeuge
machen beispielsweise die axt ist bei
mir noch aus steinen die kann ich mir
dann direkt aus eisen machen dann kann
ich das alte ding auch direkt
wegschmeißen
ich brauche irgendwie noch einmal den
sieg in den später
jetzt habe ich jeden müll und jetzt kann
einfach waren dann schmeißen wir die
steinachs herein und bahn
ganz kurz wie ich mich auf die schule
vorbereitet
[Musik]
so meine lieben freunde ich habe mich
fertig ausgerüstet ich habe mir eine
menge fackeln noch gemacht ich hab die
werkbank hier vorne abgebaut und ich
habe mir so viele seetang mitgenommen
wie jetzt hier vorne fertiggestellt
wurde im ofen jetzt ist es allerdings an
der zeit dass wir auch endlich mal in
die höhe gehen ich bin auch noch mal fix
schlafen gegangen damit die sonne hier
von neuen erwacht es wahrscheinlich
schon in der tat gesehen ich habe hier
überall so ein bisschen fichten
setzlinge hingesetzt sodass hier
eventuell demnächst so ein paar neue
fichten wachsen und alles noch so ein
bisschen verrückter aussieht liegt also
ihr wisst ja ich liebe fichten und ich
die natur kennen wir auch in minecraft
und was ich auch noch gemacht habe das
habt ihr glaube ich auch im netz gesehen
war dass ich hier vorne das feld so ein
bisschen erweitert habe so dass wir
einfach hier vorne erst mal provisorisch
schon ein bisschen weizen an pflanzen
können
viel erfolg in der hölle du gesichts
grätsche danke bruder sterben
werde ich nicht allerdings geht es los
meine lieben freunde ich nehme direkt
mal die fackeln in die hand ich nur
jetzt einfach mal die roboter um und wir
gehen als erstes links in den gang rein
wo wir allerdings direkt sehen dass wir
hier vorne schon wieder
rauskommen
ja das war es mit der höhle expedition
ich hoffe euch jetzt gefassten daumen
hoch unter dem video hier und jetzt mal
ganz kurze info übrigens kurz
zwischendurch um zwar ist das
merchandise von minecraft mit luca
staffel 1 wieder verfügbar im shop das
war relativ fix ausverkauft deswegen
haben es nach produziert einmal ein
richtig geiler vintage wetter und ein
blauer rudi also wenn er bock drauf habe
dann schon vorbei hier
vorn habe ich jetzt gerade eine riesige
kohle abgebaut und auch da oben noch
kohle und auch das eisen ich werde euch
davon keine time labs ist mehr
einblenden weil das einfach in staffel
eins viel zu viel zeit gezogen hat wie
ich einfach in time netzes
[Musik]
ich habe eigentlich gar keinen bock
darauf hier runter zu gehen aber
wir müssen
perfekt der direkt zwei ich brauche hier
vorne erst mal noch das eisen ab
haben einfach die rollo machen
einfach runter jetzt
keinen sinn ich will wirklich nicht
sterben ich habe jetzt schon zehn level
ich will ihn nicht verlieren von daher
erstmal hier die beiden babys bekämpfen
und jetzt können wir uns runter bewegen
die fledermaus verfolgt uns irgendwie
die ganze zeit schon ich werde jetzt
erstmal alles so ein bisschen
ausleuchten
[Musik]
ich dachte dass verstopfte zweite
staffel eins ich habe keine ahnung was
das hier für teile sind wir können die
abbauen und haben dann spitzen
tropfstein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe keine ahnung ob die teile
selten sind oder nicht aber ich nehme
dir jetzt einfach mal mit hier vorne es
auf jeden fall nicht sie liegt noch
unser eisen und bewegen uns jetzt
einfach mal weiter hier tief in die
höhle rein ich habe es auch dieses mal
zumindest für mich so gemacht dass sich
alles so ein bisschen dumm
[Musik]
erstmal was ist das gewesen
ich habe hier nichts bekommen
und ihr seht da vorne auch schon die
spinne
an der decke kleben
und da habt ihr jetzt auch
hass direkt mit zweite spinne ihr habt
da als auch gerade schon den ersten
neuen sound dieser staffel minecraft mit
luca gehört und zwar machen spinnen den
sound
dabei habe ich mir einfach gedacht
spinnen sind ja bei tag komplett
friedlich und bei nacht sind sie dann
erst so dass sie wütend werden von daher
dachte ich mir das passt eigentlich ganz
gut mit diesem ich habe gar nicht
gemerkt weil
man dachte das passt ganz gut weil sie
dann das dass ich kann nicht reden alter
ich habe ein bisschen schiss vor diesen
leuten da hinten ich dachte mir halt der
sound macht sinn bei den spinnen
skelett
da habt ihr auch direkt den neuen sound
von skeletten gehört
das macht einfach also dabei habe ich
mir das halt gedacht kommentar wurde
geschrieben und ich dachte das passt
ganz gut weil ein skelett ist ja ein
skelett was vorher in den menschen war
und er macht sinn zu sagen ich muss raus
ich höre schon wieder so viele komische
geräusche auf gott da oben geht
ich hab schiss
ich habe wirklich kein bock dass sie
heute irgendwas passiert ich muss auch
erst mal was essen fällt mir grad auf
ich muss erst mal wieder hereinkommen
hier in den ganze micros situation
oh
mein gott wir vorne geht es auf jeden
fall nicht mehr lange da war nur ein
bisschen eisen und daher konzentriere
ich mich jetzt erst mal wieder auf den
weg hier runter wo er hinten was ist das
muss ich das vielleicht mit der hand
erfahren
dass wir sachen aber gut freunde ich
muss mich auf jeden fall jetzt erstmal
wirklich hier auf konzentrieren weil
hier vorne ja noch das skelett war ich
weiß nicht dass immer noch hier irgendwo
am start ist ich konzentriere mich auch
erst mal hier oft ausleuchten die vorne
sind wieder so teile die scheinen nicht
allzu selten zu sein wenn überall
rumhängen allerdings muss ich erst mal
gucken dass ich irgendwie mit den
monstern aufnehme hier ist allerdings
irgendwie niemand mehr ich weiß nicht wo
die sind die sich irgendwo von mir
verstecken allerdings brauche ich erst
mal kurz die ärzte hier unten geht es
auf jeden fall nicht mehr weiter
deswegen noch mal hier vorne im kurz die
kohle mitnehmen und dann gehen wir jetzt
mal hier vorne in die seite
[Musik]
ich vergesse dass jedes mal dass wir
hier in staffel zwei sind und ich keine
vernünftige
[Musik]
mein gott oh
mein gott
da oben habe ich noch eisen vergessen
nächste
und warum hat mir gar keinen schaden
gemacht
okay wir konzentrieren und sie vorne
jetzt erstmal auch noch auf das eisen
das war allerdings noch einen blog und
hier vorne nehmen jetzt aber das kupfer
mit ich weiß auch nicht was ich mit dem
kupfer machen kann
zwar tritt irgendwie genau so häufig auf
wie eisen allerdings weiß ich nicht ob
ich mir auch kupfer gegenstände machen
kann nicht bald auch noch nicht so viel
in den kommentaren unterwegs dass ich
mir jetzt diese ganzen gruppe
ich wollte vor laufen
warum ist denn codiert ist auf jeden
fall gerade nach der perfekten direkt
eine fliege am start gewesen geh mal
ganz kurz kennen hier vorne ja danke
schön chat laser luca wurde von skelett
erschossen mega entspannt jetzt gehen
allerdings direkt auch wieder runter in
die höhle ich weiß nicht mehr genau wo
das war wir haben hier heute treiben
die kraft mich nicht an
wir gehen einfach mal ganz eng ist und
leute zwar nicht hier
meister ich tu dir nix
so
meine lieben freunde weiter geht's hier
in der höhle ich habe die fackel nicht
auf der zwei deswegen mal ganz kurz hin
gepackt zack hier vorne geht es nicht
mehr weiter hier ist nur noch ein
bisschen eisen
[Musik]
warum sollte ich jetzt hier überhaupt
nicht werkbank hinstellen und mit ofen
machen wenn ich oben mir extra neue
schmelzöfen gemacht haben und gefühlt
direkt unter der oberfläche bin und dann
können wir hier vorne auch eben kurz ein
bisschen weizen schon mal abbauen ich
weiß nicht ob das tier jetzt heißt das
ist komplett fertig ist ja heißt es
anscheinend also hier einmal wieder
hinstellen und hier vorne auch das ganz
gut mal wieder in flaschen
mein gott ich habe gar keinen bock auf
neue monster ich habe keine ahnung was
versetzt
oh mein gott das schau monster an dass
man
es sich ja tor ist geil
ich glaube
ich tue mir gerade viel zu häufig weg
als
dass sich diese folge
hier
weitermachen sollte von daher meine
lieben freunde würde ich an der stelle
die heutige episode minecraft mit luca
jetzt auch beenden wir waren zum ersten
mal
wir waren heute zum ersten mal in einer
höhle unterwegs und haben tatsächlich
eineinhalb sechs kohle bekommen um fast
1 der greisen das werde ich jetzt mal
direkt hier darauf verteilen dann
schauen wir mal eben ganz kurz ob das
vielleicht sogar passt ja doch es gibt
wirklich sehr schnell
das geht schnell danke danke danke da
auf jeden fall für eure tipps hier vorne
kommen ja die steinen sachen rein die
erde kommt hier vorne rein und hier
kommen bis die seltenere sachen rein ich
habe keine ahnung warum das tonklumpen
drin sind
kupfer kann ich theoretisch auch mal
beraten
jetzt hätte ich das mal eben hier
so auf
zack zack zack
dann habe das auf jeden fall schon mal
fertig hier fordern natürlich die holz
sachen rein die werkbank platze ich auch
mal wieder hier in der mitte und den see
tagen den restlichen kann ich mir mal
auch rausnehmen die kohle dann wieder
hier rein das schwert ich kann mir auch
noch mal eben fix eine neue
spitzhacke machen weil man ist ja gerade
kaputt gegangen das war auch der grund
warum wir nach oben gegangen sind
perfekt nicht auf das hier und dann
würde ich an der stelle tatsächlich
heutigen episode auch beenden meine
lieben freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat
dann lasst gerne einen daumen hoch unter
dem video hier da abonniert main kanal
und zeigt auf die glocke wenn ihr die
neue episode minecraft mit luca
übermorgen um 18 uhr nicht verpassen
wollt sonntag 18 uhr was soll ich da
machen soll ich noch mal runter in die
höhle sie weiter erkunden wir brauchen
halt noch ein paar neue sachen wir
müssen noch unsere rüstung voll kriegen
so dass wir dann demnächst halt
irgendwann auch auf erkundungsreise
gehen können das möchte ich relativ früh
dieses mal in dieser staffel machen um
so ein bisschen zu gucken was geht hier
noch ab was haben wir für mox et cetera
und ihr dürft aber entscheiden so
schreibt und in die kommentare und wir
sehen uns morgen um 18 uhr bei einem
anderen video wieder oder sonst
übermorgen macht
[Musik]